success is built one user at a time what
keeps them coming back apps that give
them an unmatched experience that's fast
secure mobile and always on winning
applications require best of class
performance they also need ironclad
security balancing between performance
and security used to be a tough choice
now you can have both meet IBM cloud
Internet services IBM cloud internet
services is designed for security and
speed available worldwide on the IBM
cloud platform and fueled by cloud
flares anycast network of over 140
global data centers across 58 countries
it's engineered to deliver the highest
levels of security with no compromise in
performance it elevates performance for
applications running on IBM cloud by
improving mobile experiences ensuring
application availability and
accelerating application performance at
the same time it protects against online
threats like customer data breaches and
malicious BOTS abuse with the capacity
to defend against volumetric attacks
11.5 times bigger than the largest
distributed denial of service or DDoS
attack ever recorded top flight security
and superior performance does not have
to be expensive and unpredictable during
a large-scale DDoS the cost of typical
pay-as-you-go cloud services can balloon
exponentially IBM cloud Internet
services flat billing model means you
know exactly what you're paying
month-to-month ready to get started with
our portal and API a faster more secure
Internet is just clicks away compromise
is yesterday's news a better internet
experience awaits learn more visit IBM
[Music]
you